let's uh let's go to oh I don't know
let's go to our caller from the 909 area
code who's calling today from 9 0 9 hey
David it's Pam from California
hey Sam what's up hey the impeachment
hearings from my understanding is about
you kurung right and how he tried to get
dirt on the Biden's but is it the
information that hunter was working in
that Ukrainian gas company itself isn't
that itself a third that he was looking
for no so the the the deliverable as
it's being discussed is public
announcements of investigations on the
very very bad boys Joe and hunter Biden
that's that's the deliverable the truth
of whatever was going on is secondary or
even tertiary what Trump was concerned
with was I want Ukraine to loudly and
publicly say the Biden's are bad and
we're investigating them and so on and
so forth
gotcha gotcha one more question how much
political capital do you think the GOP
is willing to lose over Trump and will
they ever recover well they're clearly
willing to lose more than they've lost
because actually the hearings are so
long and you know a lot of people just
don't have time to really parse through
it that even though it has been
embarrassing if you just look at the
substance from a PR perspective I mean
it changed when Sunland testified
because someone was brutally devastating
the Trump but I I actually on the one
hand I think Republicans can afford to
lose quite a bit of political capital
still but on the other hand as I said
earlier this week if Democrats can't
really make something very noticeable
happen as a result of these hearings the
Democrats risk losing a lot of political
capital and maybe damaging themselves in
2020 okay David all right appreciate the
phone call thank you very quickly guys
are the questions I like that that is no
no big prelude or anything like that